this morning we're learning about the
case of a California woman that's
raising concern Nationwide about how law
enforcement is using DNA evidence
collected from Crime Victims the woman
submitted her DNA as part of a rape kit
after she was sexually assaulted but
years later that unique genetic code was
used to charge her with a crime in a CBS
News exclusive she's speaking to our
Janet shamlian
at the time did you have any concerns
about submitting a rape kit no
no no privacy concerns about sharing
your DNA no this woman who has not to be
identified gave her DNA to San Francisco
police after being raped in 2016. in
hopes of convicting the suspect police
by their own admission added it to their
criminal database then used to arrest
and charge her with theft last year I
was in jail for 14 days if you had known
your DNA was going to go into a general
database would you have been more
hesitant about submitting it as part of
a sexual assault
yes
absolutely
would you have submitted it no I would
not the charges dropped after the D.A
learned how the evidence was obtained
now attorney adante Poynter filing a
federal civil rights lawsuit on her
behalf against the City and County of
San Francisco and some employees
claiming use of her DNA was unlawful
search and seizure what you have going
on here is turning the justice system
and our legal principles on their head
by gaining someone's consent to the most
personal thing they have
in their most vulnerable moment and then
storing and cataloging that and
weaponizing it against them for some
unrelated purpose it's illegal for crime
crimes but there's no such law in many
states to stop officials from storing
and using it for other purposes Jen King
is a technology and privacy expert at
Stanford University is this case an
indication that we're losing possession
of our private DNA yes it absolutely
raises some deep concerns here's a point
where someone was at their most
vulnerable gave up their DNA you know
for a criminal investigation for justice
and then had it exploited by the sfpd
San Francisco's Prime lab stopped the
practice after the incident admitting it
had also been storing the DNA of Violent
Crime Victims and victimized children
I'm not an animal I don't want no
specimen of me collected in any way I'm
not no one's pet I'm my own person I
belong to one person only and that's God
the department says it can't comment on
pending litigation though the chief
earlier this year said we own this error
the city of San Francisco told CBS News
it's committed to ensuring all victims
of crime feel comfortable reporting
issues to law enforcement and has taken
steps to safeguard victim information it
didn't say what those steps are is there
an expectation of privacy when you
submit your DNA to the police after an
assault the police when they come and
get the DNA and the permission from you
they don't tell you hey by the way you
give me this and I can use it for
whatever reason I want good bad or other
I can sell it I can let other people
access it when a woman or a person is in
that point of vulnerability and the
police say hey this is the key we need
in order to help us to help you you that
person in that moment isn't thinking to
myself I've given away my rights for a
lifetime
experts say the incident could have a
chilling effect on rape victims
willingness to come forward what do you
want to see happen I want to see Justice
I want to see
women being protected I want to see
respect for
Humanity for individuals I want respect
for myself for CBS mornings Janet
shamlin San Francisco boy then three
girls and a boy
so a very thought-provoking piece a lot
of issues there California did uh pass
legislation which Governor Newsom signed
that would protect sexual assault
victims DNA it goes into effect January
1st so there has been some change in the
movement here but lots of questions lots
of questions at least in one state
that's been answered yeah